ken you just ran to the kitchen to
answer the phone
stepped on a lego and the call was a
telemarketer
how do you feel i am pissed
what's your reaction
go tell mary i'm so mad
they just called me and told me that my
insurance in my car is at a date
mary just tell you the kids just pooped
all over the carpet
what are you doing no
no no it's too real
you're mildly infuriated don't you i'm
mildly infuriated this is my beyond
miley fury
that's what we're looking at today oh my
god let's go
applying online at best buy look at this
dumb [ __ ]
look at it we should greet all best buy
customers
true or fall incorrect we welcome our
oh god well i guess i will not work at
best buy thank you
jesus christ someone made that oh my god
that is so annoying that is
oh and then you know management's taking
like a note from like how they
you spell that the proper wording and
mindset and it bleeds into the rest of
the company and everyone's miserable
mildly infuriating isn't greeting like
greetings
welcome greeting is like
hey hi but welcome is hello come inside
you're welcome here
i feel like it should be illegal for big
giant corporations to tell
their employees how to talk oh yeah you
think so i never
that does not exist anywhere in europe
let me tell you all right obviously they
want people that are polite naturally
right
we'll see in america yeah they want
mindless drones
that seems like torture i can just
replace them it is torture dude that
yeah that's why it should be legal it's
[ __ ] up such a small thing but also a
big thing at the same time
it is very lovely though everyone's so
nice in america
that's a big difference like if i go to
europe versus america like yeah
food service like doesn't exist near no
it's like
stuff but then like in america they're
like hello can i anything
before is everything perfectly cooked oh
my god do you need a refill hopefully
but it's always kind of annoying it's
like
just shut up leave me alone i know do
your corporate thing please
leave me alone no no none of us want
this okay
i won't tell your boss okay it baffles
me that schools would throw away kids
food to deny them a hot lunch because of
inability to pay
but covet hits and now my country
provides six full meals a week to any
kids under 18 years old enrolled or not
they always had the ability to feed kids
they didn't want to
i've heard of this before where are all
the starving kids
where are they you try make a fat joke
about america right
why are we gone all right the amount of
packaging requirement for me
to buy the additional equipment i need
to use my iphone
all of this would have come in the
phone's box five years ago but apple
decided to stop including them to cut
down on packaging and waste
we're cutting down our packaging aways
thank you apple
there's there's the unboxing experience
you're gonna have the unboxing
experience and also
all the layers to prevent theft apple
yeah i don't know if this is slander but
i heard that apple used
literal child labor factories for a long
period of time but they didn't change it
out immediately
because i would have not given them
enough leverage for their other supplier
and these [ __ ] are telling me
how they're saving the environments
shut up they're giving kids jobs man all
right they're giving them jobs
they got to support their families they
wouldn't be working unless they had a
good day
it's for the environment that we're not
including the charters anymore guys
you're welcome
thank you apple thank you bless up
i say this about all the big companies
like the shoe companies like everyone's
like they use child labor in other
countries
well you don't believe wearing them
you're still getting your jordans though
i don't know
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's that weird
thing i'm like oh it's all these evil
companies but you're buying from them
it's another kind of weird thing
especially here in america like
vote for the mayor the mayor i love you
know
mom and pop shops local businesses are
super important
but i'm going to do all my shopping at
walmart so
it's just near my house come on yeah
it's just convenient they got everything
there you know saving on gas me
me me stop simping for pierre okay i get
it all right
renters demand a new dryer since this
one isn't working well let me
guess they didn't change their filter
that's a that's a face rug right there
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's the whole rug jesus i'm surprised
this whole thing didn't burn up yet and
catch the whole house
yeah that's a fire hazard i like how
they they demanded a new one instead of
just asking hey could you
check on that this one isn't working
give us a new one
a new one brand new one please you hate
to see it
cafeteria worker fired for giving out
extra food that's
so weird we want to see students go
hungry
[Music]
yeah i don't know like whenever i grew
up my family didn't have a whole lot of
money and i got to eat for free
like it was just like any other other
kids have to pay but they're like yeah
you're the poor kid here you eat for
free
wait how does it work in the cafeteria
uh well
you gotta pay like you gotta pay for a
lunch school with ranch food really
yeah yeah oh that's why they always like
lunch money take my leg mini
yeah yeah yeah there's your lunch money
that's the that's what i think
which has always been so weird i figured
that'd be like included in like the feed
like go to school
yeah yeah that is weird it shouldn't
cost that much anyway
i mean it didn't it was it's like a
dollar or something like a day it's like
a version shouldn't it be cheaper
if if everyone paid there would be a
less cost right
well instead of all the parents paying
for their kids
a different meal every time right i'm
saying that if everyone paid for the
lunch cafeteria thing food
oh it's the school charging the parents
isn't it oh i get it yeah okay
ah i thought people brought their own
food and then i forgot this lady exists
okay i got it
dumb some people do some people do bring
their own food thanks youtube i'm
grounded now because of your print ads
loudly screaming f hot girls by
downloading this app
well you know they give you ads based on
your uh
history my brother
[Laughter]
it's weird though how some ads slink in
there and you're like what
yeah oh dude there's this ad i don't
know if you've seen it
uh the kiss of ward have you seen that
where it's just
they're hot girls and they're like you
know then world war ii where they're
shooting guns but the whole ad is about
how their booty shakes when they shoot
the guns
that hasn't popped up in my videos and
you know it zooms into the butt cheek
and they pull the trigger she's like
and i watched it of course i was like
what the heck is this but
i was like i'm gonna i'm going to do a
badass video again
when designers prioritize aesthetics
over usability
original new what we see
yeah i mean that is mile infuriating is
that really how they change maps to
because yeah i can never find it anymore
really look at mine
my mom wants to look at me
oh you can't see oh yeah no it's so hard
to
find them i can't believe they did this
mine are not all monochromatic and that
changed me i like the new ones so i
don't know
oh [ __ ] yeah there's a meme about um
don't turn me into minimalistic logo
because all the brands are like
downscaling to like some simple
logo a [ __ ] man i don't care do what you
want
ain't my brand i want bigger pockets
please that's too much to ask sincerely
women everywhere
mine and my husband's oh
this system mary's like will you put
this in your pocket and i'm like
you have pockets and she's like yeah
exactly the same thing she puts her
phone in a pocket in like half
75 is sticking out it's but so it
doesn't get in the way but you don't
your figure you know you gotta
buy guy jeans i don't care yeah just buy
guy jeans just get some get some baggy
stuff it's cool
got some baggage yeah i had to go find
the head oh this is
it you found it send it to me yeah
nice 17 plus only
oh wow wow
watch youtube demonetize this video on
their own ads
[Laughter]
can't show that oh even though it's
played on your video
all right this math teacher's reason to
cut
marks oh they got a minus point because
they
didn't do three what why this is a
better version to do
it yeah it's much easier
what what an [ __ ] what is this then
draw an array to show
and solve for 10 6. it wasn't aaron
i don't even know what that is it's like
he did
four you know four across six down right
he did exactly what they asked but they
wanted to do six across four down but
screw that teacher man damn i can't
believe that
sunlight through the window melted my
keyboard
jesus where's this person live freaking
like straight
radiation rays coming through the window
well you can always buy a new keyboard
uh check out pewdiepie
ghost ai a1 yeah yeah that's what it's
called wow
you got that rgb on it i i keep it
simple minimalistic uh
not a gaming keyboard then if it doesn't
have colors it does have i just prefer
when it's red oh
my penis when i put it back in my pants
after i'm done peeing
piss drizzle the most annoying thick
thing in the universe
you gotta shake it and the rule is if
you shake it more than three times
you're playing with it right
[ __ ] i don't really get this problem
yeah nah i may have some other problems
maybe they say one of them
[Laughter]
you blur the hand so on google earth
there's a split moment that shows the
driver oh the driver the
the google no what
oh why do people do that but their stuff
out the window
yeah i think this is probably another
american thing here
i just assume everything's american
that's wrong with the world uh
so a thing that we do is people that are
in jail like convicts
not prison or anything but just like
regular like county jail
they take them into a bus and they put
them out on the side of the road garbage
bags and we can pick up all the trash
oh wow people throw their trash out a
lot so they're like oh someone's gonna
clean it up anyway
yeah exactly that's ridiculous and i've
seen so many dirty cars too it's not
like you're
doing any oh i gotta keep it clean nah
you just
got found on amazon what's wrong with it
i don't get it
it doesn't it there's just one
extra cable look how long this one is
you order it it's like freaking six
inches long
this is pleasant to look at it in a
weird way i'll take it
[Laughter]
i'm so confused what is happening they
got the pulling
back i don't know it's just why is there
a sink in their ceiling
why would you need that bro so you can
shower you can wash your head
you turn it on and you leaned over and
you spray somebody with water they come
out wet
like got him ah
i just realized too much pressure in
these things always splash your crotch
right yeah yeah and then they're like oh
what's that you had a p p drizzle
no i don't do that it never happened
yeah wait a minute god damn it
geez what is your opinion on american
bread
you've had it right well it's all sugary
isn't it yeah it's like cake yeah
i didn't know if you had it or not
you're just like oh my god i don't
really eat brands i don't know too many
carbs
right well it wasn't until like i went
to like
started traveling the other places and i
got some bread and i was like what is
what's the piece of
what is this brick what this is
substance
how am i gonna make a sandwich out of
this this is crazy
this isn't my fluffy cake bread from
from america and cake bread and when the
first time i discovered that i was like
holy [ __ ] it comes pre-sliced too what
this is
[Laughter]
yeah somebody's a psychopath here i
don't know who it is
they like a lot of chips too what the
heck is this my wife ate every single
marshmallow in a family sized box
of count chocula every single one what
the marshmallows and the cereal she ate
all the marshmallows
cereal oh it is all those american ones
i don't get it i'm like what
these are all where are the marshmallows
i don't understand
these are all outraged americans we're
looking at right now
where's my my sugar breakfast we have
marshmallows for breakfast
dude cereal is like there's a whole
aisle of just cereal in
in the uh in the stores and it's just
it's part of a healthy breakfast and
it's like 50
most important meal of the day bro yeah
got to get your milk too it's also
healthy
strong skin bread bones
oh yeah this is so annoying stop telling
me duck
ain't nobody want to say duck hey duck
not duck
duck steph okay then the one word is
like oh yeah cool
like every time i tweet anything i
always get the stupid dots in
they're so next to the space do you
notice i ever do that to you
no wait what whenever i write you they
get a stupid dot instead of a space so
it becomes like this weird and then it
capitalized a right mid
sentence and it's so annoying it gives
you punctuation automatically yeah
welcome return 8 space
it's right next to it am i the only one
no no i i do it on my phone like when
i'm like trying to i'll be trying to
google something on my phone and i'll be
like
what dot is dot and i'm just like
god dang it stop space yeah here i wrote
you rip
welcome to dot middle ground club
yes that's a great sentence thank you
autocorrect
oh
pngs without the background what is
wrong with you
ah dude tell me there's a way in
photoshop to like automatically take
that away is there
magic wand bro but still but if it's
like
if it's like a flame like and you can
see the boxes
through the flame what do you think
about that you gotta set it to multiply
and hope it's a
black background on the screen ken you
know what the actual
most annoying thing is anytime i want to
get like an arrow for a thumbnail it's a
nice extra effect
i google arrow this [ __ ] show shows
up every
god i don't want [ __ ] you arrow
i just want a god damn [ __ ] arrow
oh my god oh another amount of time i've
seen this stupid
[ __ ] show i just want an arrow
a [ __ ] arrow arrow like png like
search for that
yeah and then go to tools and then color
i think
transparent
but i don't know if it does i haven't
tried it yeah but ken look at this i'll
copy it
oh we can't you gotta you gotta download
it we can't copy paste them that doesn't
work why is there a black thing there
gotta do that that's super annoying well
because the file is transparent but
you're
you're copying it as a png so it doesn't
know how to anyway
oh that's too hard to program that's too
hard that's too hard to
protect the google images from people
like us that are trying to scalp stuff
for free to make thumbnails
now i have to unplug my lamp at night
because this furry bastard learned how
to turn it on
he turns it on every time he's hungry in
the middle of the night
oh kitty this is cute that person have a
taser on their nightstand
what is that yeah obviously to taste the
kitty once it turns out
[Laughter]
stop it all fluffy you
furry bastard what mcdonald's goddess
for working during the pandemic
oh a pen wow thank you
yeah what are you doing i'm just
like whoa this is sick you did it
that's awesome i wear that with pride
dude heck yeah
what what they call the people that work
uh they're the pandemic i forget
essential oh you're an essential worker
fancy way of saying we're not gonna pay
you anymore
but we need you to work you're essential
her hair is right in my face where is my
plane going
what the only you can see the whole
screen like what does this person
complain about
i would just whiff that [ __ ] away i
would love to get the opportunity to do
this
you would use turn around and look at
you and you'd be like
that's right or you could just be like
excuse me your hair is covering my
screen
yeah well i mean they got the head
wrists right like what are they right is
this a plane
it's a plane yeah yeah she has put her
hair on top of her chair because that
the headrest goes all the way up you
know yeah so you can just say hey excuse
me hair
covering no i'm just gonna post it on
reddit and it's super infuriating
there's no way for me to deal with this
otherwise get out the post annoys me
more than the
the meme itself yeah we have some
uplifting content you and i can
yeah we're always so positive all right
how about this one all right disney
subscribe to our streaming service for
all of our content releases mulan
also disney money please
i'll tell you what the most annoying
thing to me about these subscription
services is
wait they charge for the movie even
though it's a subscription oh okay
it's like disney plus prime or something
like that something special to get like
the new releases when they come out
instead of going to theaters but what
annoys me about streaming services
is that when they come out they have a
nice price
but then every year your price goes up
and you probably that's the sound
they're just gonna corner in the market
you think you're paying low now for
content but eventually you'll be paying
the exact same amount that you're paying
for tv that you used to do like these
packages right it's coming becoming
cable yeah everyone's like
everyone's like getting their content
that they own like disney's getting all
their content
warnings getting everybody's getting
their own stuff and like they're gonna
make their own
streaming service and it's just gonna be
the same thing all over again
but at least you'll be able to pick what
movie you wanna watch when you turn it
on
unless you're watching disney
god
[Music]
how long do they spend doing this oh my
god
what a sociopath what the [ __ ] is this
these this annoys me too not just the
not just the the alarms but
these posts where it's like my friend
asked me to set an alarm and this guy
doesn't have any friends
this person did this they don't have
friends okay they don't have any friends
i was just stabbed yeah me too
if i if i like try to peel it and i
can't get on the first try no it's a sad
that's sad probably like you like drag
the knife around the edge but it still
has like all those little pieces but
you're like whatever you put the top
back
oh yeah oh yeah new starting wages
12 an hour if you're over the age of 18
11 16 through 17
14 through 15. can you even work and
then at 8
and 50 cents jesus what what are they
mad about i don't get it
i think they're mad about how they pay
you less for being younger
yeah and yeah yeah but you're
you're starting the same job as everyone
else but just because your age is
different you're getting paid
yeah i mean i think what i'm most
infuriated about this is it says 14 to
15 year olds
how are you working at the age of 14
summer job or something i don't know
hey if i was 18 and some [ __ ] 14 year
old worker in there
they're not going to get paid the same
amount as i am let me tell you that
scroll what is the what are the titles
saying this what are they mad about do
the same work get paid less i doubt
i doubt a 14 year old can do this the
job so good as an 18 year old
right i don't know you're saying 14 year
old
but first of all i don't i still don't
understand how it's a 14 year old who's
had a summer job i did a [ __ ] job all
right
okay oh
well i think that's unfortunate yeah
this is exactly something i would
install
[Laughter]
you can just get some silicone there
yeah there we go they didn't even like
cover up the i if they were actually
going to do this you know you take off
the faceplate and then like
put something over and cover it up but i
guess they're like nah epic i guess they
wanted to keep one of them right
yeah so we want at least one place to
charge my phone on
do all moms shut your door like this
come in hey what are you doing in here
nothing
i thought it was a paint job that was
infuriating i like that i don't know
right away it was on the right like a
freaking spider painting on the wall
what the [ __ ] is that my dad was
actually the sweetie he's like
is this how you want the door closed
felix do you want to close
all the way or a little bit open like
close all the way thank you danny dude
not my parents my dad would like come in
my room like hey what are you doing in
here
you know come on come out here and help
me move the yard and just leave the door
open and i'm like
excuse me but i'm playing runescape
hey my playstation dad i'm gonna mess my
game up
i'm too shy to make videos best
superpowers
hi is it available yes it is don't eat
it me neither
nice nice man i was selling this thing
on ebay and then it wasn't selling for
the price that i put
so because everyone kept trying to
undersell me there's a new thing called
offer where
they can make you an offer so they
always offer like 100 less of what
you're selling from
so to get around that i lower the price
even lower so that i will actually get a
bidding started but then people just
started undercutting that offer even
lower
unless you're just taking the goddamn
deal
they're all just trying to undercut you
it's like stop
it i'm just gonna raise the price now
god damn it
oh women jeans wow i mean that's a
pretty big pocket for some women jeans i
ain't gonna
you know that's a that's a whole half of
a switch right there yeah
stop complaining yeah someone left a lot
of chicken on my driveway
oh hen so they just they're just like
here's a box
it's got an animal in it i hope you
found it and take care of it
sorry it i'm i
at least that's better than dropping it
off on the highway or something
oh yeah when i was growing up we had a
lot of stray dogs that we had
ah my heart dumped that one yeah it
lived like a like an area where there
wasn't any
really houses around almost like in the
middle of a field there's a bridge
nearby people always go with a bridge
and put dogs out and they're like oh i
was
up there you need a driver license for
animals
so they can drive you no but you know
what i mean what
you need a license for animals oh to
have animals yeah okay yeah
and kids do for that matter and kids too
you need to have therapy before you get
some kids
yeah find some papers or something so
that you're responsible for this animal
that all of a sudden went missing
it doesn't zoom in it took me a sec
i've actually seen this one too it's
great classic
someone said the toilet paper on fire at
your local kroger no not kroger i love
kroger
the [ __ ] is a kroger it's a big grocery
store it's got everything
yo sick socks dude all right yeah dude
look at those socks
it's on the ped aisle heck yeah i'll get
some pug socks
i'll check out and maybe i'll grab some
toilet
the final boss of the bathtub what the
[ __ ]
which one's hot water i'm dying every
time you go to a hotel and you're like
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen i'm just
gonna hope for the best
cleaner reorganized library books in
size order
oh god oh some people some people do
them in color order
um can you believe that i can't i can't
i can't even believe
some people believe some people put them
backwards because they think it looks
better
oh no why yeah that's just people that
don't even read books they just buy them
i don't know a conversation piece yeah
look at my books here
i've never read any of them but uh i
turn them around backwards because it
looks good i guess
that's a sick kitchen that's a japanese
kitchen right there that's a luxury for
japan standard oh really yeah
you don't need a counter just put on the
floor i like how the oven is above the
microwave
the cooker for the refrigerator the
cooker isn't that a cooker above the
microwave
oh so it's a fridge microwave and then a
cooker and george foreman
[ __ ] okay that will be three thousand
dollars a month
thank you very much also there's an uh
there's a fee where when you sign up and
first last month please
this is great just leave it blank no
engraving please
gotcha no problem oh man
they charge you for no sour cream
all right
is it going to get worse
dude our fridge is broken it does this
and it's been broken for like
a month now and marty has told me like
500 times to fix it and i just can't
wait yeah sometimes it like it doesn't
close properly
oh how do i fix it can't be chilly all
the time
no it's a time it's like half this size
our fridge
american fridges though damn you got it
free just figured out
shoot wow the whole wardrobe of the
fridge huge two doors on and everything
my fridge in japan let me tell you it
doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't walk to you but
you press it you give it a little
like you can hover your hand above it
and it opens up
it's sick gotta watch your head though
so you don't bump into it
gets knocked out you gotta go you need
like a walk-in freezer and you can just
like
walk in the dream
oh the where you keep your dead bodies
dead bunnies oh god they're useless
god i don't where the [ __ ] understand
why every time i go on amazon right i'm
like oh maybe they made them better now
look five stars two thousand everyone
they're gotta be so good right the best
thing
ever well they don't work ever you own a
piece of furniture they're getting stuck
under it
if you have any cords anywhere on your
floor they're gonna eat it yeah
my hair wrapped around everything that
spins inside the thing and break and you
have to clean it out every like week
you got pets well congratulations you
have [ __ ] all over your floor now
you can't open that this is the one
you'd stab
you'd stab this well you could also like
buy another one
get out of here you're right they're
still in the store stack up the chairs
this is when you're eating in a
restaurant they want everybody to leave
they start stacking the chairs oh really
yeah they don't they don't ask you to
leave they just start closing the store
until you leave i mean that seems fine
to me i wouldn't want to work out over
time just because some people are
just like right what are you going to do
it's passive aggression i mean the more
annoying thing
is the people that are staying here
maybe it's someone that works here
is a feeling i'm like look at these
people who freaking leave
hey when i worked at a hot dog stand it
happened all the time i cleaned up
everything
it was 9 55. i'm done you know
i leave at 10 and people come knocking
and they're like hey are you open
and i'm like
yes yes
dude i worked at uh i worked at a video
game store gamestop right where
they can trade in your games for like
yeah yeah yeah dude and people would
come in with like their entire gaming
collection five minutes before we close
oh crazy it would just be like no come
back tomorrow
give you five bucks tomorrow okay we're
not we're not doing this now
well that's my lane period and ken i
gotta hand it to you
if you're mildly infuriated smash like
subscribe every subscriber i get a
subscriber
check out ken and have a mild
infuriating life
sorry day